good afternoon thank you so much for
sticking with us here at 4 30 on this
monday i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian casadis christian is
the newest member of our eight news now
team he'll be joining ted and i every
day at four o'clock we'll get to know
him a little bit better
in just a little bit and throughout the
weeks but first we'll get you caught on
on some
top stories for the day a new congress
was sworn in sunday and with
it comes renewed efforts from
republicans to overturn the results of
the presidential election
our washington correspondent alexander
limon has details on what lawmakers plan
to do
and reaction president trump's efforts
to pressure officials in georgia to
quote
find votes dozens of congressional
republicans plan to challenge
the election results defend the people's
right to have
a fair and free election it's treasonous
the fact of the matter is is that the
election
results have been certified democrats
like california congressman jim costa
and juan vargas say the efforts will not
only fail
but also further divide the country it's
terrible for democracy to say
the person that won really didn't win
because we're afraid of the president
and some of his really crazy followers
and nevada congresswoman dina titus says
it's been proven
repeatedly that the election was fair
and accurate the people voted there's
been no evidence of fraud there have
been some
50 lawsuits filed and been overturned
still senator ron johnson
stands by republicans plans to challenge
the election results
we are not acting to thwart the
democratic process we're acting to
protect it democratic lawmakers like
california congressman tony cardenas
also have
serious concerns about a phone call in
which president trump can be heard
pushing officials in georgia to find
votes in his favor
i just want to find
11 780
votes which is one more that we have
with the president asked
of the secretary of state of georgia is
to lie
to the voters congress will meet
wednesday to vote on confirming the next
president
in washington alexandra limon